hey nascar fans you're back here in
kansas city live with the ceo sag nation
stone cole jones
gentlemen start your ending
[Music]
chris jones
with the gentleman start your engines
last night
hey he uh he got his engine started with
the big contract that leads to our first
question for phil on the blank today
shireen blank would be the best nfl
personality
to go gentlemen start your engines
although chris jones did a much better
job than i would have expected you know
he's not one of those guys who's out
there
with the big colorful personality i
think he did a good job i think he
nailed it who would be the best one from
the nfl in your view
it's a no-brainer mike if you say
anybody other than rob gronkowski you're
wrong because he would be the best that
gentleman starts your engine sometimes
it's ladies it's drivers start your
engine i know but now they have all
men driving i did watch the race last
night he did do a good job and uh you
know you think of other guys who
probably would do a pretty good job too
philip rivers and peyton manning for
talking about former players and i think
richard sherman would be pretty good but
rob gronkowski absolutely would be the
best guy to do it don't you think
well yeah he would be the best now
there's also the best and then there's
the most entertaining and the most that
would be conducive to our jobs things to
talk about like the anthony fauci
uh first pitch last night i'd like to
see i'd like to see bill belichick have
to do it i'd like to see how well yeah
what would there what would he do would
he would he like really
fall into it and and and get excited
about it or will it would it be the
typical flat line bill belichick uh
gentlemen um
put your uh keys uh in the uh in the
ignition and uh
and turn them
so uh i i'd want i'd want to see
somebody that we wouldn't expect to do
that's why i enjoyed chris jones i i
wouldn't have expected him to be great
and he was great so i'd like to see
somebody that you know you know gronk is
going to be good i'd like to see
somebody else and and see what they
could do
hey but it's like fouchy you have to
know your limitations mike you said that
earlier i think bill belichick has to
know his limitations he would not be
good at that job
do your job
not be one of his jobs
pete demilita has a suggestion that i
will credit him for instead of just
outright stealing it like i usually do
he suggests justin tucker the ravens
kicker doing it in opera voice which
would definitely be entertaining
i like that one yeah we go with that
all right next topic tyree killed the
chief's receiver following up on the
recent comments from chris jones that
the chiefs are going to deliver five
plus championships which means at least
six
uh tyreek hill sees chris jones six and
raises it to seven
claiming that the chiefs are chasing
michael jordan tyree kill predicting
seven rings and chasing jordan is what
shireen
it's crazy uh you know
i guess it's good to have goals but
you know we think back to aaron rodgers
when he first started his career he said
oh my gosh this guy's going to be
awesome he's going to win multiple super
bowls he's sitting here at one super
bowl toward the end of his career they
have drafted his replacement now and he
has one super bowl to his name brett
favre won super bowl peyton manning we
saw how long it took him to get another
super bowl these things just don't grow
on trees you don't go pick em and go
this is so easy and you look at how hard
it was for the chiefs last year i mean
now we think oh they have the best team
in the nfl it was hard last year they
weren't the best team in the regular
season they got down and every playoff
game had to come back
it's a difficult thing to do so to think
you're going to go win
six or seven five six seven dynasties
don't happen unless they're in new
england modern day dynasties uh and that
was only because of brady and belichick
so
i guess it's
possible but it i i'm not going to bet
on them winning more than a couple of
super bowls for sure yeah look i i mean
the the patriots won six over a 20-year
period and we're astounded by that in
this day and age with the salary cap now
look patrick holmes did a contract it
makes it easier for the chiefs to
maneuver over the next dozen years but
it really is lunacy to make that kind of
a claim when you just have one maybe if
you get to two or three i could see that
creep in proving you can go back to the
valley of zero and zero as dennis green
called it and climbed to the top of the
mountain again but the target is going
to be even larger and yeah they had to
pull a rabbit out of the hat three times
last year we had the clip of the third
and 15 play earlier with kyle shanahan
talking about how he realized we're in a
game here it wasn't a game they were
down 10 points the chiefs were with
seven minutes left they were down 24 in
the divisional round they were down 10
points twice in the first half of the
afc championship game you can't bank on
that always working out your way and i
know when you have patrick mahomes maybe
you can and maybe that's the difference
here maybe maybe all these other guys
can talk all they want and when push
comes to shove mahomes is going to find
a way to make it happen maybe that's why
they're they're confident to the point
of of delusional over the top but it's
too hard it's too hard to win one much
less two three four five six seven the
year after the patriots won their first
one what did they do they didn't even
make the playoffs in 2002. all right tua
tonka philo the dolphins quarterback
rookie fifth overall pick out of alabama
says he's ready to go sharing he'll be
starting by when
well i don't think he'll start until
after the dolphins are out of the
playoff race and with the additional
playoff teams and with tom brady no
longer in the afc east i think the
dolphins are going to stay in the race
for most of the season so i'm going to
put the over under at week 14. i think
it's going to be more like patrick
mahomes rookie season
when he played week 17 he got that one
game in and then came back and was the
starter the next year i think he's going
to sit on the bench for most of the year
especially since there was no off-season
program
so yeah i think it's going to be late in
the year they're out of the race uh if
they're in the race then i don't see
them starting this year
i'm taking the ender on that one i think
we're gonna see him by halloween i think
that that brian flores the coach of the
dolphins is not going to be worried
about
tuatanga viloa's injury history because
look at some point we got to put him out
on the field and see what he can do and
if you're going to draft this guy
you are accepting the reality that he
will have potential injuries and we need
to find out if he can protect himself at
the nfl level i i look
alex smith is not the quarterback
in miami it's ryan fitzpatrick and we
see ryan fitzpatrick you know when when
things start to go well that's the setup
for him to start to have that dip where
you start looking around for other
alternatives and
i think that uh flores at the end of the
day is going to go with the guy he
thinks gives him the best chance to win
and at some point before halloween he's
going to think to a tonga by low it
gives him the best chance to win all
right last one
vikings signing coach mike zimmer to a
contract extension is what shireen
well i think it's smart and right after
that report came out that the vikings
and mike zimmer were close to a
multi-year extension
i texted them and i just said hey i'm
really happy for you
zim is one of the all-time good guys in
this league i just can't even tell you
how much respect i have for him and tony
dungey and i've been around a lot of of
great coaches and and good men herm
edwards is another one that comes comes
to mind rod marinelli but uh zim's happy
to be there and and i truly thought he
would come back to dallas and coach the
cowboys at some point but that's not
gonna happen and i remember sitting down
with him before uh before he had gotten
his head coaching job and it took him a
long time to get one and he said you
know what when i finally get a head
coaching job 31 teams are going to
regret that they didn't give me a chance
to coach their team i believe that he
will win a super bowl at some point if
i'm he's not going to win six or seven
but i think he will win a super bowl in
his career in minnesota shireen shireen
is far too early to be drinking uh no no
and i'm not saying they won't but but i
i they look
i i think that signing him to an
extension is a no-brainer once you sign
kirk cousins to an extension i had an
argument that i made earlier this year
that with zimmer and cousins and rick
spielman and dalvin cook all entering
contract years just let them enter the
contract years just just let them go
prove it now maybe the idea with the
pandemic let's have some stability let's
do what we can this year let's hope that
it works and then let's focus on 2021.
you know they've been close they've been
competitive he's been one of the best
coaches in vikings history um and and
once you keep cousins you have to keep
zimmer and they're gonna see if this
formula eventually can work they just
have a hard time we were talking about
this yesterday when they come up against
that dominant team they have a hard time
getting it done we'll see if that
changes
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports